Rick it really is a special night for for
hockey fans especially for the Hughes family
just the ninth time in HL history Three
Brothers have played well I think it's
great for hockey I mean you know look
at the the talent of those three guys
how close they are as brothers and how much
they love each other and how much they want
each other to do so well is is really the
story for me it's it's a very close-knit
family tonight in Rogers Arena Quinn Hughes has
company in fact he's outnumbered Brothers Jack
and Luke are in town you know for one kid to
get the NHL it's really hard so for three in
one family to you know all be playing in one game
tonight that's really exciting I think we should
have a lot of fun it's it's pretty cool I would
be happy if I would be their parents for sure
soing in Jim and Allen Hughes you done good yeah
it's exciting of course first time playing Luke in
the NHL and obviously really cool but for me I'm
just trying to you know temper my emotions and
just try to focus on what I need to control 200
foot game pockets in deep here good communication
it's com in after that first period with a with
a lead here here we go come on as special and
exciting as it is to see the Three Brothers on
the the same ice in the National Hockey League
it's about winning everybody going here come on
everybody here everybody all right white black
great jump off that face off real good jump off
that draw BR is a two-on one the other way R it
BR moves in shot scores do it do it and the
devil's lead one 24 New Jersey got a minor
slipping big kill here big kill I win this clean
go back door out to the right Circle for besser
again to Pon back to besser right Circle low shot
tip they score JT Miller at the top of the crease
knocks it home m z good plays good plays we
got to get into the body hes up Jack Hughes
spins away from Tyler Myers Hughes to the front
here's hold he answers and the devils are back
back out in front good for boys Jag is the first
Hughes on the board the middle from the middle of
the corner you go to the N Kevin ball from the
blue line to the front score Jack Hughes TS it
in what a way kid hey nice mu good kick out good
kick good draw Jack good JW Curtis Lazar picks it
up wrist one in front of the flex and they score
Michael mcow diving after the loose PU and it is
four to one just's going to start making some
hard plays here big block big block there come
on Teddy here we go come on Teddy bler sets up
shop on the near side puts one in front tipped
on go by Garland rebound Joshua scores Dakota
Joshua able to Coral that Puck and slide it
in to make it four- two let's go hey hy shoot off
the wall hey 94 right right Right feet moving feet
moving feet moving feet moving come on back back
can stick down stick down get ready for him go B
go get ready for hoggy hogy hugy 40 seconds left
before the period horn comes Jack to the front to
fully stick it but it ruls up top and Luke Hughes
rips it in so now Jack and Luke have both scored
against Queen sh Luke good job you guys good job
Bo Jack R boy top and that's going to do it for
period number two let's let's try something
different right we get on the four check win
the draw if not then you play normal okay if you
want just something to think about it here we go
come on Come on B let's get back into it okay
I'm coming off the wall I might drop it to you
go Middle High middle Hogs go to the net go to
the net dumps it into the near Corner seen ther
to it hit into the end boards by hoglander
Miller gets it loose and ref besser to the
back end he scores just a strong for check and
support leads to that goal to make it 5-3 back
back back back back let's go let's go let's play
discipline boys discipline here's Patterson back
to Hughes qun Hughes R shot deflicted in front by
Sam laferty and it's a one goal game a good shift
on that last one we'll get we'll get that back all
night if play one guy in front hey get to the net
hog nice move in the line tried to shot that was
block gets it again fugh puts it on goal rebound
scores Canucks are back to square 3 minutes
15 seconds to [Applause] go we need everybody
everybody on board here final minute of the
third period it comes to the blue line that's
the support we need right there sends it down
low poot to the Blue Line ball shoots to score
jper brat bangs it in with 33 seconds to
play and that'll do it jper brat is the
hero for the devils in this one as he gets the
winning goal best to take that how he did that
massive two points for us the Hughes Brothers
their fingerprints were all over this game all
three of us are just just try to get better every
day and um you know work and perfect our craft as
much as we can so haven't really let it sink
in yet but two days going to dinner and and
hanging out has been uh great for our family
and you know it's it's nice we got the win
too I'm sure they're appreciating it more than I
am right now but um yeah it's very cool I'm sure
know you know looking back the next couple days
or months or whatever you know it'll be a cool
one